les agriculteurs les exploitants qui ont
manipulé ces substances pendant des
années alors que les normes étaient
beaucoup moins sévère
eh bien il faut savoir que leur taux de
cancer et déjà est deux fois plus élevé
que la moyenne
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé laurence de cher frédéric faure
cet ancien salarié agricole a quitté la
coopérative du gard pour laquelle il
travaillait à l'âge de 54 ans atteint
d'un lymphome un cancer du sang il en
est convaincu
sa maladie est liée aux pesticides déjà
aux meutes et l'onema y compris pendant
plus de trente ans il a manipulé des
dizaines de produits chimiques pour les
agriculteurs dans les vergers sans
protection une fois que la priorisation
et faites moi on intervenait après pour
voir sur le végétal lui-même de quelle
façon été répartis cette pénalisation un
menu intouchable pour aller voir de plus
près
j'ai d'efficacité encore une fois des
matières actives utilisées je pense que
les
les inhalations était nombreuse rue
pendant pas mal d'années suivi au chu de
montpellier il se bat pour que son
cancer soit reconnu comme maladie
professionnelle mal informé à l'époque
de son activité
il n'a pas réagi aux signaux d'alerté je
rentrais chez moi et des maux de tête
avec des amis de vomir et tout ça mais
ça c'est dans le fil du temps s'est
diluée dans l'action de de la vie de
tous les jours et peut-être plus lier
des fois la fatigue et tout ça le cas de
sébastien caricatural c'est parce que en
effet on a un nombre d'années important
une quantité impressionnante de
molécules manipulé dans un contexte donc
agricole et là on est dans une grande
suspicion permettant d'imaginer que ça
interférer dans le déclenchement de ce
maladies cancers du sang du cerveau
maladie de parkinson ou stérilité de
nombreuses études évoquent les liens
entre ces maladies et les pesticides et
pour certains concerts le risque serait
multiplié par deux en milieu agricole
dernier scanner jamais sans masque ni
gants pour ce jeune céréalier quand il
manipule les pesticides
aujourd'hui il va traiter son champ de
betteraves à sucre avec cet insecticide
pour lutter contre une chenille qui
ravage les feuilles
cette fois-là dit que ce sont dues à un
classement nocifs et se produit un
écrêtement dangereux pour
l'environnement
les nouvelles générations sont de plus
en plus formés tant mieux formés la
connaissance que laura aujourd'hui sur
l'éventuelle dangerosité ou nocivité de
certains produits
pour que les gens font de toute la
contrée de plus en plus attention
pourtant un agriculteur sur deux ne se
protègent pas suffisamment voire pas du
tout dans plus de huit cas sur dix la
contamination se fait par la peau mais
pour les fabricants les produits
dangereux ont été retirés du marché
on peut dire que globalement les
produits sont moins dangereux moins
risqué pour les agriculteurs mais en
moins d'agriculteurs doit se protéger
puisque chaque produit est accompagnée
de conditions d'emploi que l'agriculteur
de là bien entendu respecter
selon les associations il resterait
encore une cinquantaine de substances
jugées préoccupantes sur l'e411 utilisé
comme ici dans les vignes la france est
le premier utilisateur européen de
pesticides avec 75 mille tonnes par an
elle est aussi le troisième au niveau
mondial après les états unis et le japon
c'est en ce mois de septembre que l'on
commémore